un tel écran alors la décision de procéder
opération militaire spéciale mais la russie
ne peut pas se sentir en sécurité
développer
exister avec une menace constante
émanant du territoire de la modernité
L'Ukraine en 2000 et 2005, nous avons donné
Rebuffade militaire et terroristes dans le Caucase
défendu l'intégrité de notre État
a sauvé la Russie en 2014 soutenu
Crimée et Sébastopol
en 2015, les forces armées ont été utilisées pour
mettre en place une barrière sécurisée
l'infiltration des terroristes et de la Syrie dans
Russie
nous n'avons pas d'autre moyen de nous protéger
a été
la même chose se passe maintenant
cependant, nos plans n'incluent pas
l'occupation des territoires ukrainiens, nous
nous n'imposerons rien à personne
la force au cœur de notre politique est la liberté
liberté de choix pour tous en toute indépendance
déterminer leur avenir et celui de leurs
enfants et nous considérons qu'il est important que cela
le droit de choisir
profiter de tous les peuples vivant
sur le territoire de l'Ukraine d'aujourd'hui, tous
qui le veut
doit s'adresser à l'armée
forces armées d'ukraine
cher camarade et tes pères et grands-pères et
les arrière-grands-pères ne se sont pas battus avec
Les nazis défendant notre patrie commune
pour que les non-nazis d'aujourd'hui capturent
pouvoir en Ukraine
tu as prêté serment d'allégeance
pour le peuple ukrainien, ils sont anti-peuple de laisser
qui volent l'Ukraine et se moquent
ces mêmes personnes ne le remplissent pas
ordonnances criminelles
Je vous exhorte à déposer immédiatement vos armes et
rentrer à la maison
Je vais expliquer à tous les militaires ukrainiens
armées qui satisferont à cette exigence
être libre de quitter la zone
se battre et retourner dans leurs familles
souligner encore une fois avec insistance tous
responsabilité pour possible crava pro
où ce sera entièrement sur la conscience
régime en vigueur sur le territoire de l'Ukraine
maintenant quelques éléments très importants
mots pour ceux qui peuvent avoir
tentation d'intervenir
événement en cours
quiconque essaie d'interférer avec nous et ceux
plus menacer notre côté
car notre peuple doit savoir quelle est la réponse
La Russie sera immédiate et dirigera
vous aux conséquences avec lesquelles vous
son histoire n'a jamais
rencontré
nous sommes prêts pour tout développement d'événements
les décisions nécessaires à cet égard ont été prises
j'espère que j'entendrai